welcome back to las vegas now as the
weather continues to get a little chilly
uh sometimes men neglect or we simply
don't know
that there are certain things we need to
do to protect ourselves from the winter
chills
jc spoke with john salas a lifestyle
expert about how we can prepare
ourselves for these colder days
let's take a look colder weather is
coming and our next guest has the
man essentials that every guy needs
let's welcome the show
men's lifestyle expert john salas hey
john how's it going
hey how are you fantastic let's get into
this so what do guys need
this winter to look and feel great
well the first one you might know
because i see it you have great skin as
temperatures drop and
you know it's getting colder our skin
starts cracking and so we immediately
start feeling it so i'm telling my guys
we need a great moisturizer but i hear
it time and time again
oh i don't like moisturizer because you
know sometimes it feels too cakey it
reminds me of makeup
so my go-to here is a laser generous
ultra rich
hydrating moisturizer you can get it in
fragrance or fragrance free but what's
nice about it is that it's made with a
shea butter blend
amino peptides and vitamin threes which
are those key ingredients that make you
look feel
hydrated and look longer but without
that greasy feeling that we don't like
in moisturizers so
for under 30 bucks this is a great
investment you can get this curbside at
your local drugstore adlai.com
now in tandem with taking care of our
skin we also need to take care of our
hair
and our body and my secret power a
weapon that i always tell guys like what
product do you recommend for hair i
always say you got to start with
vitamins and especially with
biotin this is very great for growing
beard especially like this season after
movember when we're trying to grow out
if you're anything like me
it takes me forever to grow my beard so
this is a great way to expedite it so
take vitamins
and my go to here is frunata and the
neat thing about them is that they're
sublingual so there's no digestion in
there so you simply you know plop them
in
underneath your tongue and they just
will dissolve and they'll immediately go
into the bloodstream so the body absorbs
them
and you know they're clean with no
additives no dyes no fillers no sugars i
mean they're
as as clean as it gets when it comes to
vitamins um
it's great for beards right it's
fantastic for beers
i heard santa actually uses it for his
beard that's how santa gets that amazing
yeah that's his secret weapon every
season let's talk about comfort for guys
we've got about 60 seconds what about
comfort for guys
yeah so for cup river guys we have a
robe and this is the
man robe this is probably the bee's
knees when it comes
especially designed to give us that guys
the luxury experience when it comes to
the rope
so it's designed with fitted cuffs so we
don't have those bell long sleeves and
it also has a hoodie so you're feeling
right after you step out of the shower
and it has pockets so this is a must one
of the best things i discovered
but also along that there is some
grooming tech and we have gillette labs
heated razor and this is pretty neat
because with the second and a half
it goes to 114 degrees which gives you a
warm towel feeling like if you're in a
spa
but in the palm of your hand and last
but not least
theragan's pro this is just probably
like a game changer and i'm calling this
quite honestly probably the gift of 2020
if you're an athlete this is really
great after a workout you simply press
the button
and then you know you start massaging
yourself and it'll give you like a deep
tissue massage and it feels pretty
amazing
it's amazing total care from head to toe
we appreciate it john
thank you so much always glad to be with
you guys for more information visit
john's website which is john salas dot
com or
on instagram at hello salas